his People's Party is riding high in the
polls and his message is simple only he
is fit to lead his country where a
majority of the previous Parliament had
no confidence in him
Sebastian Court says he has confidence
in the voters recently the amount of
support for us across Austria has been
amazing so many people told us they want
us to continue working for Austria but
just as many people say you're going to
win it it's already decided my friends
this election is not yet over
analysts say court sees attitude has
been to try to pit the people against
Parliament
he's always hovering around a bit
because on the other hand he says I'm
anti-establishment we've got a new
movement not a bland old party on the
other hand he's telling everybody that
he is the most experienced most senior
most long-standing member of the
government the party that used to work
with him and then combined with others
to ask him is struggling in the polls
the far-right freedom party was forced
from office when video emerged of some
of its leaders appearing to advise
Russians how they could gain influence
over Austrian politics and the media now
its new party leader says he and his
colleagues must learn from their
mistakes and fight hard for every vote
it is worth it to continue this fight
and do everything to get a government
again with us in it which is so active
so much light and which does a lot for
our country the center-left social
democrats face a different fight having
voted with the freedom party to remove
sebastian courts they must reckon with
voters angry at being forced into an
early election every vote for Sebastian
Kurtz makes a rerun of the IB the
coalition more likely after September
the 29th and therefore there is only one
way to prevent that by voting for us
dear friends the Social Democrats in
Austria surveys suggest a resurgent
Green Party may do well on Sunday and
perhaps become a factor in coalition
forming but as the clock ticks down to
when voting starts it's clear who's out
in front in the old parliament mr.
quartz and his
party occupied all of these benches in
this part of the chamber if the opinion
polls are right after Sunday's general
election they might find themselves
spending further over into these benches
but will he and his party gain enough
seats to put them back into government
we'll find that out on Sunday evening
Dominic gain al Jazeera in the Austrian
Parliament